[Music]
good morning guys I'm Jason Jones one of
the associate curators here at the
Georgia Aquarium our doors are currently
not open to the public but we're gonna
go behind the scenes and take a peek and
see how we're caring for animals while
we're closed
I'm right now about to walk into the
building but social distancing is one of
the most important factors as we have
come to learn recently and so I'm going
to be putting on my face mask before
interacting with any of the people one
of our team members mom's actually
constructed these face masks out of
fabric and have given them to us so
that's a really awesome way to help
protect ourselves and keep us safe we've
invited our staff into two different
teams a red team and a blue team that
enables us to work for several days in a
row without crossover and that's true
for all areas within the building good
morning good how are you every day we
get a wristband in each day has a
different corresponding color so that
all of the security knows that we are
here on the appropriate day and where
we're supposed to be I am now headed up
to my office and we are in a check-in
and get ready for the day oh good
morning Jen I am all checked in so now
I'm just gonna pop on my boots and we'll
head downstairs and check in and all the
Penguins hmm so it looks like some of
our trainers are doing a quick session
with some of our harbor seals good
morning guys how's it going alright time
to go on downstairs and check on
penguins here we are at my home base
right in front of our African penguin
habitat while we have made some slight
modifications it's business as usual for
cleaning and maintaining the habitat
here at the Georgia Aquarium hi Tammy
I don't really think that the Penguins
noticed too much we're still going out
and interacting with them we're still
feeding them a couple times a day we're
still going out to the habitat and
cleaning so they may not notice as many
people out in the habitat but in general
I don't think that they notice too much
of a difference Courtney one of our
trainers is doing an interactive
enrichment session where she is moving a
bubble wand around and attempt to get
some bubbles for the Penguins to
interact with this is something we as
animal caretakers do every single day we
look for opportunities to engage with
our animals find novel things that are
different than the norm and it's a
really great way to provide some mental
stimulation and physical activity for
them as well here at the Georgia
Aquarium we have African penguins and
we've been really for
to partner with sand cub which is an
institution out in South Africa where
they rescue and rehabilitate various
seabirds including African penguins so a
couple years ago I had the fortunate
opportunity to travel out there and do
some chick bolstering and work with
their their rescue penguins before
releasing them which was a pretty pretty
awe-inspiring experience right now we're
headed into the back of our penguin
habitat so I can check on our little not
really chicks anymore our juvenile
penguins that hatch this year these guys
are growing and changing really quickly
we're noticing that that personalities
are starting to emerge some of them are
a little bit more shy some of them are
very outgoing they're although very
vocal they're still at the point where
they're eating lots of food and growing
pretty quickly but they're getting close
to full-grown size they they grow from
hatchling to the size right here within
three months developing a strong
relationship with a penguin enables us
to train them to let us look at their
wings or open up their mouths or looks
at the bottom of their feet touch them
all over
we built this relationship of trust and
so they allow us to do all these
different things and right now my purse
right now my relationship is reinforcing
enough for them so I don't have any fish
to give her now but I can use this
relationship as a as a way to reinforce
a reward the good behavior huh pretty
pretty unique family treat and we're
excited to watch them grow up all right
guys time to go check in on our adults
right now I'm stepping out on to the
African penguin habitat just to take a
peek and see what all of our adults are
doing most of them are just kind of
hanging out now the face masks or
something that they're kind of getting
used to
we'll see if they react to them but
chiku seems pretty pretty comfortable
hanging out even though we're closing
the public it's still really important
that we maintain the facility what are
you doing man hi buddy hi handsome
this is gets in one of our rescued
southern sea otters working with the
animal teams behind the scenes I don't
often get the opportunity to walk
through the aquarium and see different
aspects and different galleries
particularly when the public isn't here
so I'm right now walking into our ocean
Voyager tunnel and I get this awesome
opportunity to take a minutes myself and
just Zen out amongst all these awesome
creatures that are around me hey tank
tank is one of our green sea turtles who
is in our ocean Voyager habitat I don't
generally get the opportunity to see him
too often as I'm not down in the
galleries usually working behind the
scenes but it's a really awesome
opportunity for me to walk into a super
quiet gallery and just enjoy the
serenity and peace that that exists it's
really sad that we don't have guests
here filling filling the space but for a
minute or two it's a pretty awesome
opportunity for me so right now I'm
walking into our ocean Voyager gallery
right in front of our most iconic giant
window pane that looks directly into
this habitat which 6.3 million gallons
of water and has umpteen species of fish
whale sharks manta rays spotted rays but
I mean this is just unbelievable really
is a window into another world and we're
definitely excited to be able to share
this with you guys again in the future
right before I get back to work I'm
stopping at our tropical berry reef
habitat and this is a really good
reminder for me to let you guys know
that a lot of your local zoos and
aquariums around the country are also
going through this troubled time and
they rely heavily on your support so we
encourage you to reach out to them or
look onto their websites or Facebook
pages for more information about how you
can contribute
[Music]